the jurogan experience
to a large extent you don't know for
example if in hollywood
i wrote my first movie i think 1979 and
the guy who gave me notes on the movie
was a guy called samson rayfelson samson
raffleson is famous because he wrote the
first
talking picture that's how yeah that's
how close i am to the beginning of
hollywood so i got to win wow yeah so i
got to enjoy like 40 years of the great
the great adventure of the movie
business but the movies that i made
aren't getting made anymore a what kind
of movies well independent films
right like when i was i made a bunch i
wrote
30 30 films
for hire and i directed like 12 films on
a
which i also wrote but in those days
there was still a little bit of
independence so somebody said okay you
know what kid
i like the script what's it going to
cost uh 4 million bucks okay good here's
four million books go make the movie and
i'll sell it to uh blah blah so that was
independent film that doesn't exist that
doesn't exist anymore it doesn't no not
that i know of because
not only did that die
the movies of dead they're dead the
whole idea of movies was i'm going to
get my best gal and my best boy and
we're going to go out on a friday
saturday night we're going to sit in the
dark we're going to eat popcorn and
there's the people that are 20 feet high
they're like gods we're gonna have the
best possible time right and if i don't
like that movie i'll see another movie
blah blah blah but now the movies are
being played on this
right and the
the movies have become so corporate you
know just like twitter that all the
decisions they aren't being made by some
you know the people i grew up with you
know or ancient jews like me smoking a
cigar said yeah it seems like a good
idea go make it they're being made by 30
people sitting around a board table you
know playing playing silly buggers and
and uh pig latin with each other's
pronouns
right i get it you know things mature
and things die
who would have thought that kodak would
go out of business right
they had this magnificent hegemony they
made this little product that cost them
nothing
and the more people used it the more
they had to use it so who would kodak
would say 15 years ago oh guys you know
we have to stop there's this other thing
now but they are still making some
movies like
is it less like is it overall like a
lowered production of films no no the
problem is always in uh who holds the
high ground
right who holds the passes controls
uh
the commerce right who owns the
railroads controls the commerce who owns
the blah blah blah who owns twitter
controls the commerce so it's the suits
at the at these movies sure they own the
high ground so when i was starting out
in the theater
i had a blessing i started out in a
garage you know with william h macy and
joe montana and dennis franz and billy
peterson people became the john
malkovich the people became huge stars
we just working in a garage because we
could and we then we eventually moved to
broadway and got some
credibility because we could but if you
can't if you can only start off by
entering at the corporate level what are
you going to do
for example
the the people who made the chop shops
in southern california right they took
cars and they said wow this would be a
good idea let's take the blazer and cut
the roof off i tell you what let's take
this jeep and cut and raise the fenders
let's take blah blah blah
those were guys in the garage just like
i mean john malkovich in the garage and
all those ideas got adopted
by gm
right where they looked at this
marvelous invention say well that's a
good idea i'll do that and so this year
last year ford bought out another bronco
but if you take a a degree in automotive
design and
get hired by ford
you're going to be designing tail lights
for 10 years
right
so where's the where's the individual
initiative it's not going to exist as
milton friedman says until you give the
people with inspiration
uh
a reason to reveal it it's kind of a
brilliant thing so what's the bottleneck
is the bottleneck financial is it just
too expensive to make films so that they
try to make a film that's only going to
be financially viable they don't take
any creative choices
you know who wants to make a film that's
not going to be financial nobody ever
did you know sometimes the chance the
the the film was so expensive it didn't
didn't matter anymore the bottleneck is
the corporation which controls
the the high ground or the method of
distribution
that's the bottleneck and okay
over a hundred years vaudeville died
and then there was radio and then radio
died and there was television and then
the movies and then television then the
television drove out the movies the
movies are dead and television becomes
streaming so the the the
method of distribution
i hate to sound like a marxist is uh
determining the content
right okay so if somebody so i s you say
okay i want to uh rather than saying
honey let's go out and see if there's
anything with clint eastwood in it you
say no no no i got i bought a
subscription
right what's on my subscription series
what is what can i get on netflix right
so they're turning out sausages of
course they are but the movies were
turning out sausages too to the largest
extent i just had a good time making
them
so
i'm still trying to figure out like
what's this leap that you're making to
being like this uh hardcore conservative
or or whatever you are well like i don't
know
whatever you know i don't the hardcore
conservative is wrong the leap is i have
i have to be able to understand so your
business doesn't exist in the way that
it existed when you were coming up and
making your great films for me for you
yeah because the other thing is i was 22
years old i don't want to work with
grandpa right
i get it right the young people have a
chance to have their day and the
technology changed doesn't do any good
you know i could
to be the greatest designer of passenger
trains in the world but they are still
making independent films right yeah the
bunch of independent films how do they
get made i don't know
you don't know listen
herman melville right wrote the thing
about the big fish wrote a book about a
big fish moby dick remember him yes so
he says the first thing he says in the
book is there's no different he says the
greatest disparity in the world is
between the people who are looking for
work and the people are looking for help
right so the people looking for help
we're always saying jesus christ i can't
get good help and the people looking for
work says i can't get a job
you